hi guys my name is Tamara chambers and
this is Walter cinavia Venezia
Department they want to say it right oh
you're not the first you won't be the
last this is different every single by
the way today we are watching rocky I am
for the first time you've seen rocky how
many times it's in the hundreds probably
in high school was watching this movie
like every day pretty much once I got
the DVD and a DVD player in my room I
was just like I feel like this might not
keep my interest in a way that I'll
recognize it's a good movie but I'll
also be like I didn't really care about
it hold back seriously though if you
don't like it don't like spare my
feelings because the Rocky is part of
who I am
go ahead I'm serious just go all out if
we don't like it tell me you don't like
it what if I just did it and I was like
oh yeah it's so good it was a very edgy
weave and I'm like I actually hated it
no I did write out a couple predictions
speaking of which so this is a new thing
I thought I thought introduced this for
your show here okay so I wrote down how
many here two three four five six seven
predictions so they're on the screen now
she can't see them because this is an
editing so they're off on the screen now
oh I'm excited now look at the enjoy
okay okay
made me like my favorite love story of
all time yes first of all I have to say
I thought it was going to be more
heavily focused on the boxing oh you
would say this is wasn't what you were
expecting
sting prediction 1 complete it wasn't
what I was excited yeah but it's the
first one literally Ida got into every
review of it's about what I was excited
they didn't focus on the boxing barely
at all and then you got to defy the
fight and it was like it hasn't been
built up like you know in a movie that
was made today it would have been built
up a lot more I think I think the pacing
was a little weird in like the build up
the story about characters and his
boxing in the background
I heard people describe it to the first
sight but he's in to the other guy like
head button and I go foul foul on you
and don't do that bad bad job you know
don't do that am i right
you can it's like gonna copy permanent
break your head boys are good stressful
yeah sporting violence you're just not
into this it's something that's gonna
cause you permanent brain damage it
stresses me out okay I think the only
boxing fitness video movie I've ever
seen is Million Dollar Baby
that's a good movie though mm-hmm yeah
before I thought I thought that it was
that movie with Bernie Mac a three
thousand attention to one of the first
things that I just loved it so much it's
just like just casual street bands of it
hanging out and like singing on the
corner at your back like it be only
boxing movie to ever have an acapella
Bandhan yeah I just immediately love
with Kara I said this to you while we
were watching I had only seen him on SNL
I've never seen a movie random yeah I
think it seems too long ago and so I
just thought it might the shtick would
get old for me his whole leg moves rocky
do you yeah it did not it I'm welcome so
hard his character is so like relatable
I don't even good underdog so underdogs
are relatable but I loved him he's like
this lonely dude who just wants like
this this nice like it was 3rd person
girl friend he just was like all turtles
and really liked it I loved his love for
animals okay so did you did you like
market yes I loved another
prediction I also love the story behind
that the old was like on the street man
he was like had no like basically
homeless I think for a couple days
before they he sold the Rockies Griffin
and convinced the studio executives to
lessen star in the movie focus with his
real dog he had to sell budget and then
he got buckets back after he got finally
got say he's like I gotta get that dog
back he does a really good job like
writing himself so I didn't know that he
wrote
yeah Rocky is such a like if you get
someone else doing those jokes they
would just be like oh for sure and he's
so natural with that stuff I wrote a
little Marie yes
she runs if anybody from West Side Story
so I liked her and he's just like
telling her not to be a in his word I'm
gonna say a bad word here whore cool I
think telling her not to be so sassy but
he's like looking outward yeah
absolutely I mean that's what I keep
trying to meet everybody knows him what
you see him run down the street names
again yo Rocky do you know everybody
knows who rocky is you know yeah it's
kind of a neighborhood guy that got that
shot so now that he got the shot I went
super happy for what am i doing apart
it's the super small movement but it's
like the training montage and he's
running down the street some he just
throws them an orange
yeah it's love hands so much training
montage I mean it's pretty famous I mean
the music that's very influential or
like it's been parodied a hundred
million meals and dice yeah so what'd
you think of that would you think of
like the music and especially that
montage music would great
we're time another music earlier I think
it's like really subtle and pretty and
perfect dinner there's a lot of moments
of Jeff's silence which I really like
two training montages just like really
like yay oh good for you
ragi you get it I she's like no thank
you all this out Sonya oh hey no no no
we can't we can't have I think I've so
much fur on my shirt I have to mentioned
the date between him and Adrian at the
rink was so you know absolutely really
good moment she was so like standoffish
until that moment and you just like
talking for his life like he just
doesn't wanna lose your interest me just
like full-on just like here's a picture
this is what I did I'm a southpaw what
do all with a lot I think she plays
soccer the broken finger the ball good
works yeah every year likes us because I
said real I like it so much now didn't
know they want to watch other movies now
yeah yeah also if we're gonna talk about
cute moments of human Adrian that Hey
okay excellent no you love the kid
yes I've loved I thought you were not
gonna like the kiss or up against me
that is pretty dramatic
why didn't you think I wasn't worth it
because I know you don't kind of like
the force kissing thing and I kind of
was a little bit I drink but I feel like
in a way this might be offensive to him
but I feel like in a way that's like
that she needed that like little bit
exactly she wasn't into it
she didn't like pushing away but a few
wants also is just really sexy his lips
are great let's usually bother me in
actors particularly like Macaulay Culkin
crazy when you work here I thought that
that's something you ain't about
McCulloch um he's freaking livid minute
or so weird up with that I said you
would love Adrienne just Adrienne I love
it oh I love Asian if it's a second I
also I really love her pyramid hat with
hat she does that like the weird sense
of style it's that part where rocky
wraps is blanket around her and really
is Batman in an eight year old woman you
go good girl
I mean you have to be confident to wear
that purple super or apparently not not
if you look at the man you believe lips
I don't really imagine the front again
yeah oh absolutely anyone can flip their
hair I want to see people starting to do
that now like it's not don't hear the
sound yeah that would be a funny video
in my everyday life I flipped my hair
and I didn't makes it sound like Mickey
comes to offer his help to Rafi turns
him down and have that whole yelling
through the door thing it's so good he's
like where are you ten years ago you
weren't here for me then because he's
such a great flip in dude he just goes
into the street and like brings them
back I'm like yeah I will use your help
and you don't even hear anything it's
just one shot from really far away and
you just see him like you could tell
anything and like they shake hands at
the end he puts his arm around them and
Iraqi and Mickey
duo is born so what do you think of
Mickey I wish they gave me more of an
impression really yeah I like this
backstory of them but them together in
this film didn't like strike me but I
love what they have gone
I like a story you see more in the in
the sequels what happens with Rocky if
you yeah it gets their relationship
strengthens and really becomes like a
secondary core besides Adrian Rocky's is
rocky and Mickey why did you did you
think he was funny
yes okay well I guess it's kind of
treated wasn't an outright like I
thought he was funny but when I asked
but he was funny no point for me
maybe yell so much I love it he also
says women weaken legs and I said true
back you told me that Holly was
nominated as Best Supporting yeah and I
didn't understand it but you literally
told me right before the drunken scene
that's the yeah that's to see my gamma
nominee it's just a great game and from
Charlie Shire to Adrian yeah it's great
in there as well so that whole thing's
been tested it's so good and also Rocky
is such a good flippin dude he sits
there and takes it he doesn't like any
time that Polly has an outburst Adam or
like annoys him in any way he like just
takes it I thought you might hate Paulie
and might work use the word disgusting
but didn't do that so that's the match
against oh yeah I don't I didn't hate
Holly I wouldn't want to be his friend
right but I I think it's really nice the
depths of their relationship is getting
a five a seven correct prediction not
bad the speech about going to distance
we're about to get kicked out of that
location so they had one shot to get
that scene done and they did it all in
that one shot and it's one of the best
in the movie I think I cared about it
because I cared about the character yeah
if you get me with the characters I
don't care at all I'm a hundred percent
on the same page if you yeah they can be
the best story ever but I'll connect
with the character if there's not you
know you sympathize with people you need
to connect with them on some level
otherwise and that's why I'm not a big
fan of protagonists that aren't likable
it's hard to connect with them so like
like Ferris Bueller I really don't like
Ferris Bueller's Day Off
it's outrageous how relatable this boxer
was to me it was like how do they
capture that human experience it's
incredible on the boxing you were into
it I was looking over and
you're really hearing it and like yeah
it says a lot this is a four year old
movie and you can still connect with the
hips and you feel everything that's
going on both emotionally and seeing it
on screen just like oh that looks like I
heard I thought Rocky was gonna win and
then it didn't matter weakened to the
end who she's calling out for Adrian and
it thought did you see that she runs up
and he doesn't give a crap they're like
announcing that the Creed wins and and
he's just hugging Adrian and like
literally the most content most
wonderful moment ever she's like so stub
and and she still just looks like a
million bucks because he's so happy and
that was like stress the great acting
when that free stream comes up you know
when they freeze like right before they
go on the other side of the frame for
that hug Sloane said it was like the
absolute maximum of the emotion in the
movie because like the frame after that
he said that everything kind of deflated
and slide okay it's back to kind of
normal life that was like the absolute
peak of everything and you could tell I
mean that was it that was at that moment
still resonates with a lot of people I
don't know why this this couple stoked
to me so much but I really enjoyed them
together I'm glad you do know glad you
did I'm so glad I wouldn't be Who I am
if I didn't you know girls Rocky and
everything and it's kind of stressful to
watch something that that is that
important to you with someone who hasn't
seen it because it's like I really want
you to like it and also you really
really want to like it for you yeah but
at the same time like I want you to be
honest if you don't like right and I
would they connect with things the same
way that everyone else oh thank you so
much for being honest with me thank you
for watching everyone I'll see you next
week with something ridiculous that I
haven't see bye
okay Kim Taylor
[Music]